bienvenue à tous et leur de parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
semaines très chargées moi ça avec
marion le fait bonjour majorité une
semaine marquée par les élections
sénatoriales wernick la droite reprend
le sénat forte poussée des centristes
autre enseignement de ce scrutin la
gauche reculent dans les territoires
deux élus du front national font
également leur entrée le nouveau
président du sénat s'appelle gérard
larcher
le gouvernement a dévoilé son budget
pour 2015 une difficile équation l'état
est à la diète il doit baisser ses
dépenses mais il fait un geste vers les
ménages 3 millions d'entre eux devraient
sortir de l'impôt le déficit public lui
continue de filer et le gouvernement à
sion haut de neuf côté séries politique
entre fiction et réalité des sommes que
l'on sait la série politique française
c'est bien entame sa deuxième saison
avec l'actrice carole bouquet et pour
commenter cette semaine politique est
notre invité est philippe dallier
bonjourbonjour vice président du groupe
ump au sénat ce sénateur de
seine-saint-denis alors vous incarnez
avec bruno retailleau le renouveau du
sénat jusqu'aujourd'hui il vous ne
faisiez pas partie des sénateurs les
plus connus du grand public désormais
vice-président du groupe ump vous allez
sans doute y remédier mais sans pour
autant céder aux sirènes des clans de
votre parti alors écoutez comment vos
confrères sénateurs analyse ce renouveau
des instances de l'ump
moi je suis vendéen et philippe est élu
dans le 9-3 en seine-saint-denis donc
c'est le contraste qu'on me met un
rajeunissement et c'est tout à fait
normal et sain pour pour le groupe cette
7 e pour nous une très bonne équipe une
équipe très très dynamique et on se met
au travail maintenant au tour de notre
nouveau président et vice président ce
renouveau c'est vraiment l'image que
vous voulez donner
oui mais je commencerai par associée
catherine des roches puisqu'il y a un
président élu à bruno retailleau et deux
vice présidents délégués catherine des
roches est également vice présidente
déléguée je crois qu'effectivement une
des clés de lecture de ce scrutin à la
présidence du groupe celle envie de
renouveau au cnra donc il ya une
transmission de relais à une nouvelle
génération et je pense que c'est ce qui
explique ce résultat qui est un résultat
très large puisque nous avons été élus
au premier tour de scrutin ce qui
n'était envisagée par personne et pour
tout dire même pas par nous donc sans
surprise aussi pour vous aimez renouveau
renouveau ça veut dire qu'on ne fait
plus de la politique comme on le faisait
jusqu'à présent au sénat on balaye tout
ça est une nouvelle façon balaye tout on
verra en tous les cas je pense qu'elle
est en vie il ya une envie de
transparence une envie de vérité il ya
peut-être une autre manière de faire de
la politique avec un style un peu
différent
voilà c'est une autre génération qui
prend les commandes à écouter vous en
jugerez en tous les cas une autre
génération prend les commandes et je
pense que c'est une très bonne chose
pour le groupe ump et illégalement pour
le sénat parce que il ne vous aura pas
échappé que cette belle maison était
attaquée de toutes parts parfois à juste
raison parfois les critiques sont très
dures et injustes on va jusqu'à la
caricature
je pense qu'effectivement il y as besoin
de changer les choses de changer l'image
mais l'image ça n'est pas tout il faut
aussi effectivement agir pour changer
les choses sur le plan de l'image
justement a coûté il n'est que de lire
les grands hebdomadaires ou d'écouter la
radio ou la télévision cette maison et
cathy caricaturer et on la présente
comme la maison de retraite avec des
gens qui ne font rien ou pas grand chose
ou un travail inutile
et puis il ya eu un certain nombre
d'affaires qui ont effectivement on fait
beaucoup de tort au sénat et au sénateur
donc je pense qu'il faut maintenant
faire en sorte que nous tournions cette
page et que nous
a lyon dans une direction ou le travail
du sénat sera reconnu pour ce qu'il est
et parce que le sénat de la république
c'est une institution importante alors
qu'il ya eu des élections s'énerve à
faire le bilan c'est la vie c'est à
sénat a profondément renouvelé qui a été
élue 88 nouveaux sénateurs dont 40
femmes
on voit tout cela avec pauline dames
après trois ans de gouvernance
socialiste la droite républicaine
reprend la main au sénat si l'ump est
signé une belle progression avec 145
sièges lui dis n'est pas en reste avec
11 sièges de plus le ps on perd en
revanche disent les communistes 4 tandis
que les radicaux de gauche sont
désormais 12 à siéger au palais du
luxembourg
deux élus front national rejoignent les
rangs de la haute assemblée une tendance
qui peut évoluer jusqu'à la semaine
prochaine date butoir pour choisir son
groupe politique
si on est loin de la parité au sénat
elle progresse toutefois lentement avec
désormais 25 % de femmes contre 22 en
2011 quand le palais bourbon en compte
26 un sénat plus féminin et légèrement
rajeuni avec un âge moyen de 61 ans
contre 66 lors du précédent
renouvellement des sénateurs qui reste
plus âgés que les députés avec un écart
moyen de 4 ans maire adjoint présidents
de conseils généraux le sénat reste
encore une assemblée de cumulards avec
plus de trois quarts des élus qui
exercent un ou plusieurs mandats locaux
mais d'ici 2017 date de l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi sur le non cumul des
mandats les sénateurs devront choisir et
l'autre zoom cette semaine est consacrée
au rôle de cette nouvelle opposition
sénatoriale
à nova de bonjour vous êtes
constitutionnaliste vous avez bien sûr
suivi ce retour à droite du sénat quel
va être le rôle de l'opposition
sénatoriale aujourd'hui alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un rôle
j'allais dire qu'il peut s'imaginer se
construire s'inventer ce qui est sûr
c'est que on a eu l'expérience
d'ailleurs certains s'en plaignaient
d'un sénat à droite à la fois dans
l'opposition mais j'allais dire d'un
sénat à droite avec aussi un exécutif de
droite et parfois un sénat qui faisait
de la résistance pour pour dire les
choses simplement
d'ailleurs on a tous je pense le
souvenir récent le sénat à gauche
n'étaient pas non plus forcément une
assemblée facile pour pour l'exécutif
donc tout ça pour dire que le sénat à
j'allais dire une histoire particulière
une manière de travailler qui est
particulière qui peut être du coup fait
mal comprendre aussi
cette assemblée et qui contribue est ce
que certains aspirent à sa suppression
pour sa transformation même question que
cette élection ce qui ce qui est sûr
alors c'est je suis pas sûr que ce soit
la vraie question de cette élection je
trouve qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya un
changement tous les sénateurs à qui on
va parler nous ont dit le danger est
bien c'est qu'on n'existe plus
finalement ça fait 20 ans qu'on dit non
donc à chaque achat alors attendez c'est
deux choses différentes je dire le
discours est récurrent sur faut-il
supprimer le sénat à quoi sert-il et
c'est que sans doute il faille repenser
son rôle ou en tout cas parce que moi je
suis convaincu qu'il a un rôle d'ores et
déjà peut-être un rôle qui n'est pas
assez visible mais le faire savoir et
poser aussi la question si effectivement
une réforme des collectivités devaient
survenir de la manière dont ce sénat
devrait à la fois se saisir de cette
réforme
il en sera d'ailleurs saisi en priorité
puisque cela la constitution le prévoit
mais aussi contribué à cela et peut-être
réfléchir à un nouveau rôle du sénat
dans ces trophées comme vous attendre
des femmes et que le sénat ait sauvé
presque écoutez je sais pas si mon
talent aux périls à en péril à ce point
il est vrai que les trois dernières
années ont été très préjudiciable à
l'image du caylar d'abord parce que les
grands textes que le gouvernement
présentait était quasiment
systématiquement rejetées et non pas du
fait de l'opposition mais du fait de la
majorité et de son incohérence politique
donc renvoyé le budget avec une page
blanche renvoyait un certain nombre de
textes importants avec une page blanche
il est vrai que beaucoup on conclut et
très vite bon alors ce moment là le
sénat ne sert à rien ce qui change
aujourd'hui c'est qu'effectivement nous
allons pouvoir adopter des textes alors
profondément remanié et ça va être
effectivement le rôle de l'ump et et de
lutherie de se rapprocher et de
construire des propositions alternatives
à celles du gouvernement
donc je pense que les choses vont
changer à nouveau l'assemblée nationale
verra arriver des textes avec des
amendements qu'elle pourra maintenir
rappelons que 65% des amendements votés
au sénat ce sont en général maintenu par
l'assemblée nationale le bicamérisme va
faire son travail de cette fois le pic
est encombrant et se contenter des
miettes ses 90 ans je pense que le
bicamérisme est important d'abord parce
qu'il est dans la tradition française et
vous dirai ça les traditions parfois il
faut les changer mais surtout parce
qu'il est utile c'est-à-dire que
effectivement le travail de réécriture
et souvent de débat plus apaisé donc
moins visible là encore sur les textes
on le sait ces traditionnelles ce qui
est très vrai dans ce que disait
philippe dallier c'est que effectivement
on a eu une situation particulière ces
trois dernières années parce que ce que
vous appeliez les grands textes c'est à
dire en fait les textes qui normalement
sont le moment où se soude une majorité
et la majorité ont haussé jarre et et à
gauche voilà donc le budget le plf est
le projet de la finance on a sécurité
sociale sont des taxes on attend que
lier la un soutien à la politique du
gouvernement et dans ce cadre là c'est
vrai que sur les trois dernières années
il ya eu un moment je pense
d'incompréhension général qui a conduit
sans doute à ce que ce qui était
satisfait que le sénat passe à gauche
puisque on disait que c'était impossible
se demande si finalement ce n'était pas
une chambre
ingérable quoi quelle que soit sa
configuration politique
techniquement l'une des conséquences est
aussi qu'il n'y aura pas de réforme
constitutionnelle alors on raisonne si
l'on à l'étranger si l'on raisonne en
termes de majorité j'allais dire
arithmétique
oui sans doute parce que les majorités
requises sont trop élevés pour que ça
puisse permettre une invasion
constitutionnel c'était sans doute déjà
le cas avant et j'ajoute que sur le cas
particulier par exemple du droit de vote
des étrangers on se souvient que le
sénat bascule en à gauche l'a
immédiatement voter qu'il y avait par
ailleurs des difficultés parce qu'il
fallait que ce soir voté par l'assemblée
et finalement la réforme n'a pas été à
son terme
donc oui en même temps je ne suis pas
certaine qu'il faille toujours des
réformes constitutionnelles je pense
qu'il ya sur un certain nombre de
questions des réformes législatives qui
peuvent avoir un effet institutionnels
tout aussi significatif et que donc il
faut pas se focaliser alors que ce soit
la réforme des collectivités
que ce soit parce que c'est un peu dans
l'air du temps aussi la question
d'éventuelles d'une réforme des modes de
scrutin certains aspirent à
l'introduction de la proportionnelle
ce sont des questions dont en toute
tranquillité dont en toute tranquillité
et indépendamment même et partage droite
bush
on peut se si jamais les assemblées à
novak vous restez avec nous on va passer
au mardi mais parce que on va parler
d'une primaire à droite à l'ump a choisi
son candidat sont candidats pour le
sénat bien évidemment est le grand
gagnant de cette primaire à droite et
l'ancien président du sénat gérard
larcher qui a devancé très largement au
premier tour l'ancien premier ministre
jean pierre raffarin et philippe marini
philippe dallier
on a beaucoup évoqué cette question
est-ce que c'était à votre politique ou
pas politique au sens
vous avez entendu très bientôt une
gestion entre nicolas sarkozy françois
fillon et d'autres ça n'était pas la
seule grille de lecture mais je pense
qu'il faut finalement oui et c'est
peut-être la principale malgré tout et
je l'avais dis pour ma part à jean
pierre raffarin je pense que le choix
des sénateurs s'est aussi fait en
fonction de l'actualité
à l'ump et au regard de leur volonté
d'indépendance ça je pense que c'est ce
qui a marqué ce scrutin
jean pierre raffarin avait fait le choix
de
de s'afficher alors qu'il faisait partie
du trio qui fait toujours partie du
triumvirat à la tête de l'ump
il s'est engagé derrière nicolas sarkozy
et certains ont eu un effet tivement
peur que le sénat ne devienne
effectivement une antichambre de la rue
de vaugirard pour le dire vraiment
encore pour certains si vous voulez
finalement mais attendez pour certains
vous savez vous avez 143 bien 143
membres dans le groupe je pense que les
raisons sont certainement différente
d'une personne à l'autre mais je pense
que la volonté d'indépendance du groupe
ump au sénat est certainement une des
raisons principales de la victoire au
premier tour et aussi nettement de
gérard aschieri sénateurs ont revendiqué
une liberté de vote ils sont rebelles 7
sénateurs
écoutez oui je vais envie de vous dire
oui parce qu'on l'a vu sur un certain
nombre de textes vous savez quand on
était au gouvernement moi je me souviens
à l'époque avec une trentaine de
sénateurs du groupe ump on avait dit on
ne votera pas la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle en l'état et on a à
l'époque faire reculer le gouvernement
et le texte a été profondément modifiée
à quoi sert-il d'être parlementaire si
on met toujours ce que l'on pense au
plus profond de soi sous son mouchoir et
si on se range systématiquement à la vie
de la formation politique
on a envie d'indépendance et c'est peut
être aussi ce que les français nous
réclame sortir de la langue de bois dire
ce que nous pensons et agir en
conséquence
ahmad ce vote pour notamment gérard
larcher pour vous ça vous a surpris ou
pas qu'il soit gagné dès le premier tour
on nous annonçait un match tellement
serré oui il faut toujours se méfier
j'allais garder annonce qu'il y avait il
ya des trois candidats je crois que les
candidats étaient assez différent et
sans doute effectivement les éléments de
contexte
ont-ils eu q
jouer cela dit c'est vrai aussi que
gérard larcher a l'expérience pour le
coût de la présidence de sylvain
j'entendais tout à l'heure évoqué le
renouvellement au sein du groupe
il me semble pas forcément d'ailleurs
incohérent qui ait eu un choix de entre
guillemets continuité pour la présidence
du sénat et au contraire de profond
renouvellement au sein de l'ump c'est
peut-être finalement une sorte une forme
d' équilibre interne dans le cadre du
choix du groupe
ce renouveau c'est ce que vous voulez
incarner cette indépendance côté rebelle
des sénateurs c'est là la marque que
vous allez imprimé sur ce groupe
côté rebelle écouter on va relativiser
mais c'est vrai que donc on est plutôt
jeune et on a envie de faire bouger les
choses alors on va essayer de le faire
bouger ce que vous nous avez tous les
cas il est écrit dans la constitution
qu'il n'y a pas de vote impératif choc
parlementaires votent en son âme et
conscience bien évidemment nous
appartenons à un groupe et il faut qu'il
y ait du dialogue de la concertation que
nous essayons ensemble de construire des
textes bon maintenant après chacun se
prononce en son âme et conscience
voilà nous sommes favorables à un sénat
le plus libre et le plus indépendant
possible assène le vase pour cet
éclairage
on va continuer à un petit peu palais du
sénat car l'autre fait marquant du
scrutin c'est l'arrivée du front
national au sénat le parti de marine le
pen et qui a réussi à envoyer deux
sénateurs au palais du luxembourg qui
ont fait une arrivée remarquée marie
vraiment arrivé devant le sénat à pied
pour les deux sénateurs frontiste vous
venez au sénat pour les supprimer
on vient au sénat pour y travailler
voilà les ce sont les les grands
électeurs qui sont eux-mêmes les
représentants du peuple qui nous ont
demandé de le faire nous allons le faire
avec sérieux comme nous savons le faire
depuis longtemps
l'image est forte c'est la première fois
que des élus d'extrême droite font leur
entrée dans la haute assemblée
un dispositif spécial de sécurité a été
mis en place
un nombre impressionnant de journalistes
a fait le déplacement
mais très vite la question est posée que
peuvent faire deux élus sans groupe
le sénateur des bouches du rhône veut y
voir une étape bien sûr que c'est une
étape bien sûr les élections
présidentielles les élections
législatives
deux députés les élections municipales
ces villes conquises alors qu'on nous
disait que c'était impossible
ces élections européennes et ces
élections sénatoriales qui était la
place gardé la chasse gardée du système
eh bien nous en voyons aujourd'hui les
grands électeurs les français envoie
aujourd'hui deux sénateurs front
national rassemblement bleu marine c'est
une étape de plus il ya la dernière qui
méthode qui nous tend les bras en 2017
prochain objectif pour les deux
sénateurs trouver leur place au sein du
sénat
david rachline est en effet le benjamin
de l'hémicycle un autre symbole demain
lors de l'élection du président du sénat
c'est lui qui recueillera les votes de
ses collègues sénateur philippe dallier
comment vous analysé cette élection de
deux front national des grands électeurs
décomplexée ou perdus face à l'état de
la politique aujourd'hui ces deux
élections étaient inscrits ou quasiment
inscrits dans le résultat des élections
municipales de mars dernier
il est quand même à noter effectivement
oui je vais justement préciser les
choses
grosso modo le front national pouvait à
l'échelle nationale compter sur un
millier de voix et il semble qu'ils en
aient recueilli quatre villes donc ça
montre aussi effectivement et je pense
que c'est particulièrement vrai dans les
territoires ruraux où les élus sont
assez peu étiqueté politiquement ils
sont soudain sans étiquette il est fort
probable qu effectivement qu'un certain
nombre d'entre eux face aux difficultés
qu'ils connaissent dans l'exercice de
leur mandat
eh bien elle choisit de porter leur voix
à faire sévices et qu'ils ne viennent
plus vers vous ni vers la gauche
ceux qui ont fait ce choix là
effectivement quelques pas on est seul
on n'est même plus dans un vote de
colère on est presque dans un vote
d'adhésion aux abonnés aux territoires
ruraux
alors que vous ne répondez pas ils sont
peut-être pas généraliser mais c'est
vrai que les collectivités locales et
notamment les plus petites vivent une
période extrêmement difficile la baisse
des dotations de l'état la réforme des
rythmes collège scolaire qu'il est
impossible de financer
il ya tout un tas dessus à la
disparition des départements finalement
on ne sait plus où veut aller le
gouvernement donc tous ces sujets ont
profondément marqué la campagne
sénatoriale
je pense effectivement qu'un certain
nombre d'élus de ces territoires ont
choisi de pousser un coup de gueule en
portant leur voie vers ces listes
qu'elle soit s'assurer du front national
à la haute assemblée
mais pas connu jusque là votre rapport à
ses élus que ce que quand vous avez vous
croisé dans les couloirs qu'est ce qui
va se passer
il a rien se passer de particulier à ce
que j'attends c'est de les voir
s'exprimer en commission et de les voir
s'exprimer en séance voilà c'est moi ce
qui m'intéresse ce sont les idées le
reste voilà ce sont des élus de la
république
ils sont sénateurs aujourd'hui point
barre souvent on pose la question à
chaque élection à ce qu'il ya un ancrage
aujourd'hui du front national avec cette
élection au sénat
il est évident que lors des dernières
élections municipales le front national
a obtenu un certain nombre de voix ils
ont remporté un certain nombre de
collectivités locales donc il faut
effectivement s'interroger sur les
raisons qui ont poussé les français à
choisir ses candidats plutôt que les
longs tous ceux de la gauche
on va passer au mercredi philippe
dallier c'est le grand jour ces jeunes
élection au sénat
et c'est donc gérard larcher qui a été
élu au deuxième tour président du sénat
ils accèdent au plateau pour la deuxième
fois après avoir accédé une première
fois entre 2008 et 2011 il promet une
défense des territoires et une
opposition constructive face au
gouvernement
on va écouter ses premiers mots une fois
son élection à la majorité
je veux m'adresser pour lui dire qu'une
tâche l'attend est une opposition
constructive avec pour boussole
l'intérêt du pays en ces temps de
difficultés à mes collectionna teur de
l'opposition je veux dire que je serai
le président du sénat de tout le sénat
de tous les sénateurs attentifs à leurs
droits
mes chers collègues nous avons une
responsabilité collective
il faut que nous donnions sénat plus de
force que nous fassions temps de savoir
que cette question lancinante sur
l'utilité d'une assemblée ne nous soit
plus posé moi j'aimerais comprendre ce
concept une opposition constructive
ça veut dire quoi est-ce que vous êtes
un opposant ne dirais pas ça veut dire
que sur certains textes et en fonction
de l'attitude du gouvernement bien
évidemment le sait la même dans
l'opposition au niveau national
pourraient être amenés à adopter un
certain nombre de textes en les ayant
modifié
on verra effectivement quelle est
l'attitude du gouvernement de consacrer
7 effectivement ça c'est aussi une
maîtrise de l'agenda du sénat qui
pourrait être une maîtrise
j'allais dire comment la qualifier je
vais pas dire intelligente mais on sait
bien que si le sénat le veut il peut
retarder les textes du gouvernement
nous ne sommes pas dans cet état
d'esprit ce que nous souhaitons c'est
effectivement pouvoir faire avancer les
choses et notamment sur le sujet des
collectivités territoriales mais ça
dépend d'abord de l'attitude du
gouvernement
y aura-t-il une seconde lecture sur le
texte que nous avons examiné avant l'été
la question se posait encore où vous
allez le gouvernement avec le prochain
texte qui va venir sur les régions tout
ça est encore très flou et c'est le
gouvernement qui doit effectivement
faire signe de bonne volonté
est ce que gérard larcher devient
aujourd'hui le principal opposant à
manuel valls et françois hollande pense
pas que l'on puisse dire cela c'est le
président du sénat donc principal
opposant il n'est pas un troisième
personnage de l'état dans l'ordre
protocolaire mais pas dire qu'il est le
principal opposant les sens là plutôt
aux partis politiques mais en tous les
cas ici nous allons examiner les textes
et le gouvernement sera face à la
majorité du sénat et face au président
du sénat qui j'en suis certain
aura à coeur de faire respecter le sénat
entre 2008 et 2011 gérard larcher avait
réformer le sénat il avait mis fin des
privilèges
est ce que cette réforme va continuer
j'espère bien parce qu'effectivement on
entend beaucoup de choses là dessus des
choses justes et des choses profondément
erronée qui m'agace parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui les conditions de travail
des sénateurs sont quasiment les mêmes
que celles des députés à très peu de
choses près et on a l'impression en
lisant la presse que ici il y a des
supers privilèges
ça n'est pas vrai mais pour autant je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin dans un
certain nombre de domaines sur la
transparence au sein des groupes
politiques et ça nous allons nous y
atteler pour ce qui concerne l'ump
fameuse réserve donc pour parler de la
réserve parlementaire également
l'indemnité
des sénateurs sur leur assiduité leur
présence en commission s'écouter un tout
petit effort a été fait précédemment par
jean pierre bel mais à mon sens c'est
trop peu je pense qu'il faut aller plus
loin effectivement il n'y a pas de
raison que les élus les plus absents et
les mêmes conditions que ceux qui font
acte de présence de manière très
régulière donc bien plus loin et je suis
certain qu'il ira bien plus loin
mercredi le gouvernement présente à son
budget pour 2015 l'état est à la diète
21 milliards d'euros de baisses de
dépenses cela ne suffira pas pour autant
à contenir le déficit et le gouvernement
elle assume revue de détail des
principales mesures de ce budget avec
elisa berthelot mais la principale
mesure de ce projet de loi de finances a
été annoncée par manuel valls il ya
quelques semaines le gouvernement entend
modifier le barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu après les 40 milliards de baisses
de charges accordées aux entreprises
d'ici 2017
des mesures vont être prises en faveur
des ménages la première tranche de
l'impôt sur le revenu sera supprimé
trois millions de ménages sortiront de
l'impôt 6 millions verront leurs
prélèvements diminué
nous avons également pris la décision
d'adapter le rythme de réduction des
déficits à la situation économique du
pays
il me semble utile de donner quelques
éléments d'explication sur ce point
notre politique économique ne change pas
mais le déficit se réduira plus
lentement que prévu du fait des
circonstances économiques très faible
croissance très faible inflation
autre mesure annoncée dans ce plf la
hausse de 2 centimes du litre de diesel
et une augmentation de trois euros de la
redevance audiovisuelle
en parallèle le gouvernement poursuit sa
politique d'économies - 7,7 milliards
pour l'état et ses agences - 3 7
milliards pour les collectivités
territoriales - 9,6 milliards pour la
protection sociale
objectif réduire le déficit mais à un
rythme ralenti
j'avais parfois entendu dire que c'était
une mesure injuste parce qu'elle aurait
bénéficié à l'heure et bénéficier à tous
non elle bénéficiera aux modestes et
moyens
j'ai parfois entendu dire que puisque ça
baissait pour les installer augmenté
pour les autres non il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation d'impôts pour les autres
d'ailleurs 2015 sera la première année
où il n'y aura aucune disposition dans
la loi de finances qui est une
conséquence en terme d'augmentation
d'impôts sur le revenu pour 2015 le
gouvernement prévoit une croissance de
1% et un déficit ramené à 4 3% du pib
des prévisions que la haute autorité des
finances publiques chargées d'émettre un
avis juge fragile est ce que vous
pourriez voter ce budget 2015 tel qu'il
a été très sage je ne je ne crois pas le
problème de ce gouvernement c'est sa
crédibilité en matière économique et
financière depuis qu'ils sont aux
affaires ils n'ont cessé alors de
changer de politique dans un sens
heureusement mais ils ne vont pas assez
loin et il n'y a encore aucun effet le
pack 2 de responsabilité avec les
entreprises pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de traduction concrète mais en matière
budgétaire c'est catastrophe sur
catastrophe sans quasiment 100 millions
et les assurances propose notamment
françois fillon mais ça se fait sur cinq
ans ceci étant dit là c'est 50 milliards
sur l'exercice 2015 2016 2017
mais il ya donc très gros doute parce
qu'en fait les économique gouvernement
devra réaliser elles ne sont pas
documentés
on ne sait pas encore et on voit bien
d'ailleurs qu'à la première annonce de
réduction de certains crédits on a des
levées de boucliers les frais sont
quasiment nulles et pour l'inflation
effectivement ça sera également très
faible ce qui est un handicap en matière
de création de richesse donc ce
gouvernement navigue à vue et ne cesse
de repousser les objectifs maintenant
c'est peut-être 3 % en 2017
voilà il ya un manque de crédibilité
totale total et je pense que le débat au
sénat sera intéressant comme à
l'assemblée nationale et j'espère que
louise nous allons pouvoir effectivement
adopté un budget qui sera profondément
remanié donc la commission des finances
en tous les cas pour la majorité
là se mettre au travail et je pense que
nous serons en capacité de proposer un
certain nombre de choses pour aller plus
loin et plus vite parce que l'argument
du ministre est de dire il faut pas
effectivement que les prélèvements tue
la croissance mais il faut peut-être
aussi essayer de faire des économies
plus rapidement et ça on va écouter il
va y avoir un certain nombre de sujets
ils essaient mais à dose homéopathique
je vais me dire qu'il faudrait les
homéopathie jeu sur le non remplacement
des fonctionnaires qui partent à la
retraite
effectivement il faut aller plus loin et
plus fort parce qu'on sait que la masse
salariale de l'état
et c'est la même chose pour les
collectivités locales c'est une très
grande partie du budget de l'état et
donc il fait fonction publique aussi
nicolas sarkozy le propose mais moi je
moi je serais favorable à ce qu'on
repasse de 35 à 39 heures dans la
fonction publique bien évidemment ça
fait 12 % tout d'un coup alors à effet
différé mais ça représente 12%
effectivement d'économies potentielles
sur la masse globale qui est très
importante
si nous ne prenons pas ce genre de
décision nous n'en sortirons pas et nous
n'atteindrons pas nos objectifs et je
vous rappelle qu'on a dépassé cette
semaine et 2000 milliards d'euros de
dettes et que ça c'est un risque grave
issos sur la france que vous préconisez
drastiques en tous les cas des mesures
certainement plus fortes que celles qui
sont proposées là et ça va toucher aussi
l'ensemble des français sur les impôts
que ça vous fait rire les amis écouter
qui peut croire que nous allons
redresser la france sont que chacun soit
mis à contribution
le tout c'est qu'effectivement les
efforts demandés aux français soit le
plus juste et plus équilibré possible
mais vouloir faire croire
qu'effectivement et c'est ce que le
gouvernement fait en proposant de
supprimer la première tranche de l'impôt
sur le revenu regardez ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont fait rentrer dans l'impôt
sur le revenu un tas de gens qui n'y
étaient pas ceux qui paient des sommes
effectivement assez faible le rac au
double et là ils vont résultat on va
concentrer l'impôt sur le revenu sur les
classes moyennes
c'est vraiment la politique de
gribouille c'est un pas en avant deux
pas en arrière
je pense qu'il faut remettre tout ça sur
la table et arrêté une position et je
pense qu'il ne faut surtout pas
s'interdire une augmentation de la tva
c'est ce que le gouvernement
ça se murmure un jour on nous dit oui le
lendemain on nous dit non je vous
rappelle que nous avions adopté le
principe de la tva sociale en janvier
2012 que la gauche arriver au pouvoir
s'est empressé de la supprimer
et je pense que ils ont fait une grave
erreur parce que on sait bien qu'une
hausse de la tva n'entraîne pas
forcément une augmentation des prix et
surtout on met à contribution tous les
produits importés et nous savons que
nous importons donc hausse de la tva
pour nous a été dessinée effectivement à
financer les allègements de charges pour
rendre de la compétitivité à nos
entreprises voilà donc c'est vraiment la
politique de gribouille et la
crédibilité du ministre aujourd'hui elle
est proche de zéro et c'est ça le drame
parce que je vous proposerai à l'aube
l'examen
rendez vous à l'automne au sénat à
l'automne exactement un autre examen de
projet de loi cette fois à l'assemblée
nationale il s'agit de la transition
énergétique qui a débuté cette semaine
un texte très attendu c'était l'une des
promesses de campagne de françois
hollande
aujourd'hui porté par la ministre
ségolène royal qu'on va écouter la
condition de réalisation de dépenses
dans le cadre d'un bouquet de travaux
est supprimée afin de permettre à tous
les contribuables des bénéficier du même
niveau dette publique
quelles que soient les opérations
engagées et le séquençage des travaux
pour la ministre qui pose un petit peu
et font de ce débat on a beaucoup
entendu depuis dimanche dernier quand on
a fait ces élections au sénat d'une
espèce de consensus qu'on pourrait
trouver sur des grands thèmes
on voit là la transition énergétique
pourriez porter avec avec la gauche par
exemple je pense que tous les français
doivent se sentir concernés par le
problème du réchauffement climatique
d'ailleurs on constate dans l'autre pays
mois après moins d événements qu'on
n'avait pas connu le règlement en tous
les cas sur l'analyse des choses oui il
peut y avoir consensus mai consensus à
n'est pas un gros mot
il peut y avoir une vraie crise de
conscience il faut que ça puisse faire
avancer un peu mais parfois je cite
lacan qui disait le consensus est le
seul cas de figure où la connerie pour
du sens mais ça n'est pas toujours le
cas dans certains cas ça qu être le cas
mais pour le coup sur un thème sur un
sujet comme celui là effectivement je
pense que ce que chirac disait il ya
quelques années la maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs j'ai un
peu le sentiment que c'est encore way le
projet doit aujourd'hui par de grandes
ambitions
vous ne partagez pas mais on peut si on
partage les ambitions après la question
c'est parce que la france en est là ça
va être la question du financement parce
qu'on sait bien que faire en sorte que
tous les bâtiments publics et ceux des
particuliers soit effectivement mieux
isoler et qu'on aille vers la réduction
de la consommation du gaz ou du fioul
on sait tout ça demande énormément
d'argent et du temps et de l'argent
aujourd'hui on en a plus beaucoup et par
exemple si on parle nucléaire qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des centrales mais bien sûr
qu'on les garde là aussi françois
hollande a été d'une écoute et je pense
que nécessité fera loi et qu'il sera
bien obligé d'en passer par là parce que
nous n'avons pas d'autre solution donc
mais c'est le drame de françois hollande
pendant sa campagne électorale et son
fameux discours du bourget pointant du
doigt la finance promettant monts et
merveilles à tout le monde
voilà je pense qu'au fond de lui même
mon avis il est convaincu qu'on doit
garder le central mais société mais les
deux d'abord parce que les centrales les
centrales nucléaires effectivement sont
beaucoup moins polluante alors ya le
problème du retraitement des déchets
mais ils sont beaucoup moins polluante
que le charbon que les allemands
utilisent maintenant beaucoup parce
qu'ils ont fermé leurs centrales
nucléaires et que ne parlons pas du gaz
et du pétrole donc il faut effectivement
garder nos centrales nucléaires
et puis encore une fois 2000 milliards
d'euros de dette nous ne pourrons pas
tout faire en même temps donc je pense
que ça aussi en tous les cas il faudrait
pour les démanteler investir des sommes
considérables
il faudra investir également de l'argent
pour leur permettre de durer mais nous
avons un atout en france aujourd'hui
c'est ce nucléaire et une électricité
qui est moins cher qu'ailleurs on ne va
pas passer ça par pertes et profits
simplement pour plaire à madame duflot
jeudi c'est un rituel chaque année à la
reprise de la session parlementaire les
députés et les sénateurs se sont
retrouvés pour les journées
parlementaires
les communistes se sont réunis à
martigues pour leurs journées
parlementaires les verts eux et et à
amiens avec la visite du président de
l'assemblée claude bartolone puis celle
de la ministre de l'ecologie ségolène
royal la majorité tente de soigner ses
alliés et appelle au rassemblement de la
gauche
écoutez cécile duflot et jean vincent
placé
chacun a tiré le bilan de ce qui s'est
passé nous on a vu que l'on pouvait
avoir un accord s'ils n'étaient pas
respectées on pouvait pas faire vivre
cette coalition majoritaire mais je
crois qu'un certain nombre de
socialistes se rendent compte de la
difficulté de gouverner avec une
majorité extrêmement réduite il faut
retrouver les vertus de ce qui a été
fait ce qui était dit pendant la
campagne présidentielle
et cette dynamique là doit se retrouver
sur des propositions très précises sur
la transition énergétique sur la
biodiversité
oui la bataille budgétaire n'est pas non
maintenant la période ne s'y prêtait pas
et puis pour des questions d que 2000
tout simplement il faudrait vous
proposer plusieurs images en tout cas de
ce qu'on appelle des bons titres de la
presse des unes de presse qui ont fait
cette semaine on a beaucoup parlé vous
propose d'abord regarder dans le figaro
c'était des propos qui ont été tenus
visiblement par jacques chirac qui a
pris fait et cause pour alain juppé s'il
avait l'énergie dirait directement ça
serait prêt au qg de la jupe est en tout
cas et j'ai toujours su qu'il serait au
rendez vous de son destin et celui de la
france qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
après jacques chirac avait qualifié à la
jupe et du meilleur d'entre nous à
l'époque je pense qu'il considère
toujours qu'elle a ajouté le meilleur
d'entre nous c'est parti c'est lé coup
pour coup maintenant trajet
là mais qu'au sein de la droite
républicaine et du centre
il y est effectivement un certain nombre
d'hommes en l'occurrence mais il
pourrait y avoir des femmes qui soit en
capacité de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle avec une bonne chance
d'être élus c'est plutôt une chance pour
notre camp le tout est effectivement
c'est que tout cela ne tourne pas à la
guerre fratricide avec un résultat qui
pourrait être qu'à les prochains mois
comme écouter n'ont pas forcément moi je
trouve que les propos que tient elle à
jouer alain juppé sont des propos
mesurés il n'essaie pas quelqu'un qui
est dans les petites phrases et ça c'est
quand même très bien juppé fillon
il ya eu d'autres propositions qui ont
été à la une de presque pâle avec
notamment ce matin à manuel valls dans
la croix vous allez le voir dans un
instant il assure que la gpa sera
interdite la gestation pour autrui
en france il n'y aura pas non plus de
reconnaissance automatique des faits des
enfants nés à l'étranger par procréation
médicalement assistée
dimanche il va y avoir une manifestation
de la manif pour tous justement où en
êtes-vous à l'ump sur ces questions est
ce qu'il y aura un retour si retour de
la droite au pouvoir retour sur cette
loi du mariage pour tous ces écoutes et
moi je vais vous donner mon sentiment
personnel
on voit bien avec les déclarations plus
ou moins clair les des uns et des autres
que c'est un sujet compliqué
juridiquement d'abord mon sentiment
c'est que il n'y aura probablement pas
de retour en arrière sur la loi il
faudrait d'ailleurs qu'on m'explique
juridiquement comment il serait possible
de des mariés les gens qui se sont
mariés ça pour moi ça m'échappe enfin je
suis membre de la commission des
finances est pas de la commission des
lois
peut-être que mes collègues pour m
expliquer mais j'ai le sentiment
effectivement et on l'a bien vu avec la
la relative prudence de nicolas sarkozy
je pense qu' il n'y aura pas de retour
en arrière maintenant que des garanties
très sérieuse et absolue si possible
soit donné en matière de gpa et pma je
pense que c'est effectivement ce qu'il
faut obtenir et les propos de manuel
valls ce sont des propos des propos
rassurants donc maintenant
on sent que vous êtes assurés a coûté en
tout les cas la déclaration que vous me
montrez et la une de la croix
effectivement ce sont des propos
rassurants parce que la gestation pour
autrui
là ça serait vraiment la ligne jaune qui
seraient franchis et je pense que très
très très majoritairement les français
ne souhaitent pas que nous allions dans
cette direction et je ne souhaite pas
non plus donc il va effectivement
falloir voir ce que le gouvernement fera
dans ce domaine donc si on retient la
leçon il n'y aura pas d'abrogation de la
loi sur le mariage pour tous mais
écoutez là je vous dis je vous donne mon
sentiment personnel
maintenant je ne sais pas qui sera élu
en 2017 je ne sais pas qui sera premier
ministre mais qui sera moi je pense que
ce n'est pas souhaitable et qu'on ne
pourra pas le faire de toute les
manières parce que juridiquement c'est
un ca serait abrika cela est quelque
part vous vous opposez aussi là à bruno
retailleau le président du groupe ump
mais il avait pris quand même des
positions assez durs pour le mariage
porteuse est mais au sein de l'ump il ya
des positions qui sont effectivement
très différente si vous écoutez alain
juppé je pense qu'il a vu
j'ai dit la même chose qu alain juppé
nicolas sarkozy a été prudent et quand
j'écoute un certain nombre de mes
collègues juristes nous savons bien
qu'il y a beaucoup de difficultés là
dessus et donc moi je pense que nous ne
reviendrons pas en arrière là dessus
rolex est quand même à sogeti climat
dans votre dans votre candeur par mike
liban font c'est vrai que la manière
dont françois hollande est abordé le
sujet et et rencontre est très clivant
et cette semaine nous allons passer aux
plus de l'edough consacré au retour des
hommes de l'ombre
les hommes de l'ombre c'est cette série
télé politico policière sur les
coulisses du pouvoir politique les
premiers épisodes de la saison 2 était
diffusé sur france 2 un président de la
république confrontés au difficile
exercice du pouvoir une première dame
alcoolique bipolaire qui ne supportent
pas l'elysée la décomposition de
l'exécutif voilà pour le pitch
les précisions de simon barbarie deux
ans que les fans l'attendaient
cette semaine la série les hommes de
l'ombre était de retour sur france 2 et
après la conquête du pouvoir de la
saison 1 c'est son exercice qui est
illustré dans cette deuxième saison
le président de la république alain
marjorie hommes politiques de gauche
connaît des débuts difficiles à éviter
crise conjugale et politiques s'entre
choquent comme un petit air de déjà vu
j'ai jamais touché un sou d'argent
public or est si tout avait été fait
selon les règles mediamax se seraient
pas encore l affaire il n'y a pas
d'affaires commencent à y est prête à
faire la demande et à la trentaine de
journalistes qui adorent s'y est pas
inintéressant
ça va retomber camp si l'histoire
emprunte à l'actualité récente
un président de la république pas à la
hauteur de la fonction pour ses
adversaires ou encore une première dame
dépressive et incontrôlable al'inverse
de son lointain cousin la série
américaine house of cards le pouvoir tel
qu'il est décrit dans les hommes de
l'ombre mais pas un but en soi mais un
moyen de mener une action qui dépasse
les intérêts personnels
on n'a jamais intérêt dit le président
le président qu'elle se soit représente
la france doit l'aider à grandir à la
hauteur de sa fonction
non c'était du grandiloquent entre new
york et si la fiction politique à la
française respecte est un peu trop les
arcanes du pouvoir
ici les compromissions et des coups bas
sont plutôt dicté par les circonstances
que par des esprits cyniques et
machiavélique alors manque d'audace ou
crédibilité les téléspectateurs et les
politiques jugeront alors le scénario a
été écrit il ya plus de deux ans
finalement les scénaristes ont anticipé
la décomposition du pouvoir est ce que
c'était si prévisible voilà une question
une question très difficile
moi je lui je n'ai pas vu cette série
dont j'aurais du mal à en parler il
c'est vrai ce qui m'inquiète ça peut
avoir un côté sympathique amusant ce qui
m'inquiète c'est je me demande si le
téléspectateur sera faire la différence
entre la fiction et la part de réalité
parce qu'effectivement comme il ya des
ressemblances voulu voilà où s'arrête la
fiction où commence la réalité et je
suis déjà suffisamment inquiets de
l'image très négative de la classe
politique aujourd'hui
écoutez ça peut jouer parce
qu'effectivement quand on montre
l'arrière-cour et tout ce qui peut s'y
passer
parce que les scénaristes traitement
mais c'est vrai mais je préfère que la
justice fasse son boulot sereinement et
de manière indépendante pour régler ces
problèmes et faire en sorte que ceux qui
se comportent ainsi se retrouvent dans
les tribunaux plutôt que effectivement
des fictions qui mélange un peu tout et
qui ne feront encore qu'aggraver le
sentiment de rejet de la classe
politique parce que derrière c'est quand
même la république qui est en cause
et vous allez-vous ça m'inquiète en ce
moment vous ne riez pas écrire ou
petites séries fictions politiques sénat
alors absolument droit non ce n'est pas
ça le sénat le favoritisme et
conseillant comme les affaires
le favoritisme les affaires comme vous y
allez il ya eu il ya eu effectivement
des choses qui qui pose question je le
redis notamment dans le groupe ump et
nous allons tâcher avec bruno retailleau
de tourner cette page là et de faire en
sorte qu effectivement plus jamais cela
ne soit possible
elle a fait beaucoup philippe dallier
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation pour
parler à moins de nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine
merci